[Music]
[Applause]
equality is one of the most influential
and powerful words in the development of
what our society is today it is the word
that represents fairness a word that
signifies justice a concept that people
have fought for and then has
revolutionized our global culture in
innumerable ways today I challenge you
to consider a different side of equality
one that isn't always positive my
question today is can this amazing
concept of equality have another side
can equality ever be unfair if you were
to look at America about 150 years ago
you would find that it was radically
different from the America we know today
for example this was a time where women
were expected to wear a large hoop skirt
and a very tight corset a time when
lower-class women were expected to have
a labor-intensive job such as a servant
a factory worker domestic health etc
middle and upper-class women were
expected to either help with the family
business or to become a homemaker this
idea of equality inspired both women and
men alike to start a revolution that
would come to completely change the face
of society for the better let's take a
look at mother Teresa born August 26
1910 st. Teresa of Calcutta was accepted
into the low radial convent in Dublin
Ireland at the age of 18 from there she
was sent to India although she was not
an American in 1999 she was voted by
Americans as the most admired person of
the 20th century her goal in life was to
provide help to the helpless home to the
homeless and loved to the lonely in her
words let us always meet each other with
a smile for a smile is the beginning of
love through her work she advocated for
the rights of the people who society had
deemed unworthy she dedicated herself
entirely to her goal and by doing so
became one of the most respected and
beloved people ever to live and she was
a woman Amelia Earhart she was the first
female aviator to ever fly solo over the
Atlantic Ocean did you
the Earhart was so admired by the public
that people would write her and tell her
that they would name things such as
children lakes and even sometimes homing
pigeons Amelia after her her heart once
said women must try to do things as men
have tried and if they fail their
failure must be a challenge to others
these amazing women are just two
examples of the many people throughout
history who not only broke stereotypes
but demolished them they completely
destroyed the idea that women weren't
strong enough or qualified enough to
change the world
now women's rights is no doubt one of
the first things to come to mind would
think of equality it rightfully gives us
a sense of pride and accomplishment this
brings us back to the question of how
can equality possibly be unfair let's
take a moment to compare the word
equality with the word equity as you can
see both words have the same prefix that
means equal and at first you may notice
the only difference between these words
is two letters a and L I'm here today to
tell you that those two letters make all
the difference if we break through the
layer that is the a and the L we realize
that equality and equity have about as
much in common as left and right now
don't get me wrong I'm not saying that
equality is a bad thing rather that it's
not the best option for every situation
such as this one personally this is one
of the most powerful images I've ever
seen it beautifully illustrates the
concept so hard to explain
as we can see equality represents
sameness which in some situations is a
great thing equity on the other hand
represents fairness which in all
situations is the best thing when each
child is the same number of boxes not
everyone can see
but when each child gets the amount of
boxes they need all three children are
able to see over the fence my father is
a special education science teacher and
has been for the last 11 years he says
that the very first thing he has to do
is determine what the students current
levels of educational functioning are
and from that he can modify
their assignments and their exams to fit
their current needs he says that he
views his job as leveling the playing
field to set every student up for
success leveling the playing field in my
perspective to level the playing field
means to give every student the
opportunities and tools to compete as
equals in the game of life now this not
only applies to special education
students but to gifted students as well
research shows that roughly 18 to 25
percent of gifted people are under
achievers they simply quit trying
because nothing they do leads to any
measurable success or satisfaction and
in my opinion this is unacceptable
school is supposed to good place to
learn and to grow but not all students
grow well in the same conditions
oddly enough neither do plants a cactus
can store water for long periods of time
it doesn't need much of any attention
and it is very large and very strong in
orchid on the other hand is a small
delicate flower that needs the precise
temperature and amount of water in order
to survive so if you were to plant an
orchid in the same environment of a
cactus and expect them both to bloom
you'll be sorely disappointed likewise
if you plant students in the same
classroom environment and expect them
all to flourish you'll once again be
disappointed not taking the time to
think about every student as an
individual is like telling a flower then
it's not beautiful and that it doesn't
deserve to bloom because its petals
aren't the exact same shape or color as
all the other flowers but really if you
think about it no two children or
flowers are exactly alike imagine
instead if schools were focused on
equity rather than on equality on
providing the students with what they
need rather than teaching everybody the
same way I strongly believe that the
learning environment should reflect the
learning diversity among all students in
all schools at my school I'm in a class
where we have the opportunity to learn
in whatever way best helps us to
understand if you can see us
on a normal day you might see some
students standing some sitting alone at
a computer with headphones in some
working in a small group and maybe even
some working with the teacher who is
helping them now to create the situation
in every classroom wouldn't be easy at
all it would take extra time extra
effort and extra manpower but in the end
leveling the playing field would instill
self-confidence in the students and help
them to achieve their full potential to
shine bigger and brighter than ever my
message for each and every one of you
today is not to overlook those two
seemingly insignificant letters because
though they are small they represent the
difference between equality and equity
between fairness and sameness and my
question is what flower doesn't deserve
to bloom thank you
[Applause]